Hey Guys! It's hajime.
トミック：トミー
はい、というわけでやってまいりました。
今日のYouTubeの動画です。
ト：今日のビデオでしょ？
今日のvideoです。
ト：No,”video”
No,No,No,”video”
ト：No,ヴィデオ
No,No,No,…
(爆笑)
まぁ、今日はちょっとやりたいことがありまして、
YouTubeで人気の動画っつったら何かなと思って
いろいろ調べたんですよ。
なんかいろいろあるじゃないですか。
ト：マインクラフト
そう！マインクラフトとかね。
アンパンマン
おもちゃ
ト：妖怪ウォッチ
あー、ありますあります。そういうのですよ。
人気のものって決まってるんすよ、
YouTubeである程度ね。
で、俺たちも再生されたいわけじゃないですか。
もっともっと。
ト：まぁね。
で、僕はなんかこういろんなYouTubeの動画を見てて、
子供用のおもちゃってあるじゃないですか。
わかる？アンパンマンとか、リカちゃん人形とか、
メルちゃんとか、アンパンマンとか、
子供がたくさん見ればいいんですよ。
YouTubeの動画は(笑)
なので、やっぱ俺のチャンネルで
もっともっと見る人を増やすためには、
やっぱ子供向けのコンテンツを、
作らなきゃいけないと思って、
今日はちょっとトミックさんと二人で、
子供の真似をして、
ちょっと子供っぽく、おもちゃを作っていこうかなと
ト：んんっふふふ～
絶対再生されると思います。
子供の気持ちにならないと、見てもらえないと思うんで、
まぁ我々も身も心も子供になって、
子供のおもちゃをちゃんと紹介しようと思います。
まぁちょっと実際にやってみましょう。
イメージとしては、
子供が、寝る前にお父さんとお母さんに無理矢理
動画を撮らされるイメージ。
想像つきます？
ト:うん、想像つく…
ちょっといやいややる感じです。
こんにちはー　ト：こんにちはー
あ゛ーーーーー　ト：はいどうもこんにちは
お兄ちゃんちゃんと自己紹介して
こんにちは！はじめです！
ト：こんにちは！とみおです！
はい今日は、この商品、開けてくよ！
ぽぽぽぽぽぽぽぽぽぽ…(笑)
(笑)
ト：じゃあ、こーれーをーあーけーてーあーそーぶーよー！
１個ないよ！　ト：何？
１個なくなっちゃった。　ト：うそ？
盗みましたか？　ト：盗んでねぇよ(笑)
おい！俺のシルバニアファミリー！　ト：爆笑
おい！どこ行きやがった!?　ト：爆笑
おおーい　ト：おおーいじゃねぇ。
ト：4個しかないよ。
あ、4個入りだったわ(笑)
ごめんね、ごめんね。
ト：人の胸倉つかまないでねー
ごめん、難しいね社会ってー
今日は、これを、トウ(しょう)かいしようと…
お、あ、一個あ…潰れちゃってる…
くそぅ！！
ト：はっはっはっはっ…
「シルバニアファミリー ミニシリーズ」
ト：三階建て…ｎｋ…
ト：うわわははっはっ なんだよー
これはどんなおもちゃなんだい？説明してごらん？
ト：三階建てのおしゃれなおうち
ト：パパー？
何だい？
ト：開けていーいー？
いいよ、でもとみおは、お兄ちゃんなんだから、
先に、はじおに開けてあげな。
ト：はーーい
開けてお兄ちゃん！
ト：開けていいよ、はじお。
ありがとう！
ト：(笑)
可愛い子猫ちゃんが入ってるよ！
ね！
全部開けよ、お兄ちゃん！　ト：うん。
わーーーーー！すごーーーい！
あ！りすさんが、いる！
3番あけます！　ト：3番。
あー、うさぎさんだー！
ト：4番。
早くー！
わーーー！！
ト：あっ、うさぎさんだ！
被ってんじゃねぇか。
ト：お母さん、お母さん。
あっ、なるほどー！　ト：パパとママ。
あーーーーー！！！
ト：わーすごーい。作るー。
作ろう作ろう！
やばい！すg…
クソ簡単だね！
ト：クソ簡単だねー。
どっちが速く作れるか競争しよう！
ト：競争競争ー。
オラァ！！
わぁすごいs…あれでしょ！お庭でしょ！
ト：お庭だよー。
ト：あ゛ーーーーー！！！
あ゛ーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！
苦情来ないんスか？　ト：こない。
あれ待ってシール一個捨てちゃったかな？
やべやべシール捨てちゃった…
うぇん、シール捨てちゃった…
ト：笑笑
うあ゛ーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！
う゛ぇーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！
あっ、あったわ。
わあ゛ーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！
できたーーーーー！　ト：うわなんだよー
ト：なんだよぉーー
僕たちの、シルバニアファミリー
の、家が、
でーきまーしたーーーーー！
ト：僕が作ったのは、
おにわーーー
と、4かーーーい。
わーーー、すごいすごい！
これ、ブランコなの？　ト：ブランコ。
１人乗せてみていい？　ト：うん。
こいつ乗せてみよう。
うさちゃん、がんばれ、がんばれ！
ト：うさちゃん、がんばれー！
がんばれーって、ほら、みんなね、…
ト：(笑)
わーすごーい！　ト：わーい！
ト：なあい！
ト：せっかく作ったのに何してんだよこらぁよぉ…
(笑)ごめん…
おへやーー！
ト：うわーーーぁあ～～？
ト：わあ～～すごーい！
ト：ねぇ…あ、たぶんこれは違うと思う。
ト：これはたぶんここ…k…庭なんじゃないかな。
あーなるほど！
あっ！！
お兄ちゃんが今ねこちゃんをやっちゃって…　ト：あ～ごめんね～ごめんね～
すごーい！
というわけで、ぜひ、
小さいお友達も、
大きいお友達も、
作ってみてね！
ばいばーーーーーい！　ト：うわわああーー
あっ！　ト：あっ！
ト：(笑)
ト：汚い
あ゛ーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！
ト：汚い！！！